la médiature youtube est probablement
l'élément le plus essentiel pour être
découverts et pour être cliquer pour
qu'on vienne voir votre contenu je vais
vous expliquer dans cette vidéo comment
créer des miniatures facilement sans
logiciel et vous allez voir c'est
extrêmement simple
de plus en plus de chaînes youtube jours
et il est extrêmement difficile de
réussir je partage avec vous toutes les
astuces les meilleures techniques pour
avoir des vues des abonnés et enfin
réussir sur youtube
inscrivez-vous à rachel et activer la
cloche pour ne manquer aucune vidéo
comment faire une vignette qui
permettent de gagner des vues comment
créer une vignette sans que ce soit trop
compliqué il existe plusieurs solutions
pour créer des vignettes soit vous
pouvez faire directement sur photoshop
mais ça demande déjà d'avoir le logiciel
un certain investissement
et puis des connaissances à acquérir il
existe des solutions qui sont beaucoup
plus faciles et aujourd'hui je vais vous
en donner une qui est extrêmement simple
qui est gratuite permet de faire de
belles vignettes et qui est à la portée
de tous avant toute chose que vous posez
la question du jour comment est ce que
vous créez vos vignette
quels sont les points indispensables et
qu'est ce que vous mettez en place vous
pour avoir de belles vignette
mettez moi tout ça en commentaire et moi
je répondrai directement à toutes vos
questions il ya toutes vos suggestions
avant de créer une vignette d'un point
de vue purement technique il faut
connaître quelques éléments
indispensables dès lors commence à être
un peu connue que vos abonnés veulent
voir votre contenu il est extrêmement
important d'avoir votre tête ou du moins
éléments identifiables qui apparaît sur
votre vignette afin qu'on clique
directement dessus il faut savoir que la
plupart des spectateurs sur youtube
cliquer sur une vignette regarde les
vignettes il regarde quasiment pas les
titres une vigne et de t'être
actionnable elle doit être personnalisé
elle doit aussi inciter au clic c'est
extrêmement important
les messages que vous êtes donnés tout
au long de votre vidéo doha être
clairement résumé sur votre vie n'y est
par contre il faut absolument que le
contenu de votre vidéo soit en parfaite
corrélation avec votre vignette sinon
c'est du pit à cliquer ça veut dire que
vous avez une belle vignette on va
cliquer dessus et après le contenu à
l'intérieur n'est pas bon dans ce cas là
vous n'a cumulé pas tendu vous allez
avoir des dislike vous n'aurez aucun
abonnement et ça ne servira à rien une
vignette
être pensé bien fait optimiser jeu tout
de suite vous montrer quels outils
utilisés comment faire beauvignac et
vous allez voir c'est extrêmement simple
la toute première chose à faire quand
vous allez faire votre vignette c'est
déjà dans un premier temps de faire une
capture d'écran d'une de vos vidéos pour
pouvoir l'utiliser en décor principal
alors on va prendre quelque chose un
petit peu un petit peu au hasard par
exemple celle ci je fais une capture
d'écran directement sur mon ordinateur
je vous montrais un site internet qui
fonctionne super bien pour faire vos
miniatures et surtout qui a le mérite
d'être gratuit fait www.canwea.ca comme
vous allez dessus et là vous vous
inscrivez vous en ti fier avec facebook
avec quelle google comme vous le
souhaitez ou alors avec une adresse
email a personnellement je le fais avec
facebook vous arriver ensuite sur votre
compte pour créer votre vie n'y est
qu'il faut vous fassiez sais que vous
allez utiliser ici des dimensions
spécifiques pour faire une vignette
youtube il faut se mettre en 1920 par
c'est la résolution full hd tout
simplement vous créez votre canevas de
base sur lequel vous allez poser
directement tous vos éléments à ce
moment là ce qu'il faut faire c'est
importer vos images donc nous on va
importer la toute dernière photo
convient de faire télécharger votre
propre image
on va sur le bureau on prend la dernière
le dernier élément qu'on a qu'on a pris
en capture d'écran là il est en train de
se télécharger le voilà maintenant je
vais l'agrandir pour pouvoir l'utiliser
c'est bien pour illustrer je vous fais
pas la miniature de dingue mais vous
allez comprendre le process et voir
comment ça marche
à partir du moment où vous avez votre
photo on va conserver toute une partie
là sur la gauche pour pouvoir illustrer
et pour pouvoir poser du texte on va
imaginer qu'on va par exemple faire une
vidéo qui s'appellera comme celles par
exemple que j'ai fait le jour 10 astuces
pour débuter youtube
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
utiliser différents éléments dont comme
moi ce que je vous propose de ce que je
vous conseille de faire c'est déjà
d'insérer des formes on va prendre des
petites formes qui nous permettront
d'avoir des éléments de fond sur lequel
on va insérer notre texte
il ya des éléments gratuit il ya des
éléments payants il ya déjà beaucoup à
faire avec le gratuit
rassurez vous on va prendre un carré
comme celui ci par exemple pour insérer
dise voilà on le mettra en couleurs pour
que ce soit pêchue et que ça ressorte un
petit peu on peut faire une rotation et
là je vais le positionner là et je vais
les positionner pour tous mes mots vous
allez voir c'est super simple hop comme
ça je pourrais mettre différentes
tailles différentes façons de l'affiché
et il y aura un côté très très dynamique
je mets un peu de côté pour ajouter deux
de la dynamique 10 astuces ça sera le
terme le mot pour on peut l'écrire de
plein de manières différentes alors pour
s' est pas un mot très très important
donc on va pas nécessairement le maître
en très très gros des astuces pour et
ensuite débuté hop il sera un peu plus
gros parce que c'est quand même un terme
qu'on doit comprendre le terme des buts
et hop un peu plus gros toujours de côté
je le mets là et vous allez voir ensuite
on va dans texte je vais ajouter un
titre
et là je vais m je vais taper mon 10
alors 10 voilà là j'ai mon disent je
vais le prendre je vais le posez là la
police n'est pas terrible on peut la
modifier directement ici on va choisir
une police quelconque 1 celle ci par
exemple voilà on va l'agrandir pour
qu'elle passe bien dans toute ma case
qui 56 ça devrait fonctionner je peux
pareil l'incliner pour que ça
corresponde à l'inclinaison
de ma partie en dessous mon cadre voilà
dix astuces up qui vient se positionner
par ici sur lequel je vais mettre une
rotation également je vais reprendre la
même police qui n'est suggéré ici je
peux le mettre en un peu plus grand vous
pouvez mettre des majuscules et
minuscules n'hésitez pas à changer à
apporter avec quelque chose d'original
avec une lecture un petit peu rigolote
un petit peu différente je le
sélectionne je le mets dans la bonne
police
je le mets de travers j'ajoute en titre
débute et hop dans la bonne police
je le prends je le décale je le mets là
je le nez de travers et je le centre et
ensuite on va pour retrouver youtube on
va dans chercher et là vous allez avoir
plein d'imagés par exemple pour l'image
youtube je tape ça me propose différents
logos des gratuit du payant
moi je prends celui ci il se comprend
très bien cellules grâce à mon avis deux
logo youtube
je le prends et ce que je vais faire si
je vais mettre aussi un petit peu de
travers pour ajouter un peu de dynamique
sur voila je peux aussi le mettre un peu
en arrière-plan si je souhaite un pour
savoir une passe sur le débuter ce que
je vais faire si je vais aller dans
organisé je vais aller d'en arrière
voilà ça me le poste derrière et on
comprend tout à fait de quoi je parle ce
qu'on peut faire proche de la dynamique
c'est de mettre des cadres de couleur
par exemple ici alors à la place du 10
ans ce qui est en dessous par exemple je
vais sélectionner et je vais choisir ma
couleur ici je met des couleurs un peu
de punch y un mois là très clairement
j'ai fait un truc un peu au hasard un
petit patch work pour qu'on puisse se
faire sa propre idée
astuce je vais le mettre en rose
un pur je vais le mettre
on va le mettre en orange débutée on va
le mettre en bleu voilà et là on a un
début de vignettes où on comprend deux
compères alors après on peut rajouter
une idée d' inciter à l'action par
exemple en mettant une petite souris qui
va cliquer sur youtube par exemple donc
dans ma barre de recherche là je vais
taper mouse par exemple en anglais voilà
donc là j'ai une idée de souris j'ai un
doigt je peux le réduire je le tourne ça
mon ami de lui je le supprime le double
clic est une mauvaise idée
voilà je le mets là ça m'incite à
l'action et après on peut rajouter plein
de choses on peut mettre les pouces vers
le haut des pouces vers le bas comme on
le souhaite il ya un autre élément que
vous pouvez faire parce que là vous avez
quelque chose de très tonique vous avez
des couleurs qui flashent vous avez un
logo youtube qui flashent ce qui est
très important que vous pouvez faire
c'est ce que je vous conseille
d'ailleurs un cdh allait rapporter un
peu de tonus à votre image de fond vous
double cliquer dessus ça vous fait
apparaître la partie filtre en haut à
gauche
et là vous allez modifier un petit peu
votre image alors vous avez des
préceptes qui sont déjà pré-enregistrées
vous pouvez utiliser
je vous le conseille pas fait le par
vous même moi ce que je vous conseille
c'est d'augmenter un petit peu la
luminosité dans une proportion à peu
près 10% augmenté aussi un petit peu le
contraste de 10% un petit peu la
saturation 10 15%
mais que ce soit pas trop et ensuite
vous verrez votre image ce sera tout de
suite plus punchy ça sera beaucoup plus
sympa on peut voit là vous voyez vous
réajusté en fonction de votre image des
conditions dans laquelle elle a été
prise pour vous ayez quelque chose qui
soit vraiment raccord avec le reste de
votre
avec le reste de votre miniatures et une
fois que vous avez fait ça parce que
vous faites c'est très très simple vous
allez sur télécharger png vous pouvez le
télécharger en png en jpeg ou pdf comme
vous le souhaitez alors pour une
miniature savez du png ou du jpeg pas
autre chose et vous cliquez sur
télécharger ça va à ce moment-là vous
enregistrez vous l'exporter
l'enregistrer directement dans votre
navigateur
et vous n'aurez plus qu'à la récupérer
et à l'envoyer sur youtube c'est
extrêmement simple
merci d'abord regarder cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous aura aidé à créer
des miniatures personnalisé est
extrêmement simple à mettre en place
si le contenu vous a pu hésiter pas à
laisser un gros pouce vers le haut à
vous abonner parce qu'il y aurait encore
plus de contenu pour vous aider à
développer votre chaîne pour avoir des
vues qui se convertissent en abonnés
merci à vous et quant à moi je vous dis
à très bientôt
salut